[Music]
don't hesitate go commit you gotta
commit the reason why people who are
less talented than you people who are
less smart than you are winning is
because they are spending time out doing
taking action but life cannot deny that
someone who gives their absolute all
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message commit fully over
to you Will Smith also if you want to
know what Will Smith has to say about
building confidence and excellence check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the links to join are in
the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet I've never
seen myself as particularly talented
where I excel is I'm willing to die in
the process of acquiring skill
[Music]
commitment man it's like that life is
hard right
like yeah you might get hurt it's like
you know you're you you're your heart
might get broken you know it's like you
might lose your job but you still gotta
commit you know you gotta commit you
know what I mean and it's like you know
you meet somebody and you hey you know
you like her and she likes you and you
hesitating
don't hesitate go commit you gotta
commit you know you might get hurt you
might lose something but it's like you
can't experience the the joy that is
intended for you in life if you don't go
you gotta go man what if the only thing
that was keeping you from having Will
Smith level success was just having the
courage to say go and take action your
Will Smith level life is on the other
side of go but you don't want to go
because you're afraid you're afraid of
rejection you're afraid of failing
you're afraid that it won't work out but
unless you decide to go you're gonna
live your life on the sidelines watching
people with less talent than you win
because they chose to better themselves
and you didn't so I look at my tour as
an example I'm about to go on a 90 day
23 City tour from January to April 20
1998 it along the way and I'm scared I'm
terrified my biggest fear is letting
people down my biggest fear is going to
an event and nobody shows up or one
person shows up and they're disappointed
and I get to relive that fear every day
every four days going to different
cities and doing another event and at
the same time this is what brings me the
most alive this is what I'm the greatest
in the world that this is where I shine
helping entrepreneurs especially in a
one-on-one setting or in a small group
setting is where I come alive it's where
I bring the most value it's where I push
people out of their comfort zone and
where I get people to actually take
action on the thing that they've been
holding off for the past three months
and so the thing that I am best at is
also the thing that I'm the most scared
of and so going off and doing a
to her vent is terrifying but it
requires me to press go because of item
press go then I'm gonna watch other
people start making money start crushing
it's having an impact and I know that I
could have done that and even bigger
fear for me is regret knowing that at
the end of my life look back and say I
was too afraid to take action I was too
afraid to press go I could have done
something bigger I could have had a
bigger life I could have played a bigger
game I could have done a lot more I'm
disappointed with myself I regret it now
it's too late to do anything about it I
don't want to be that person and so I
need to press go I'm pressing door on my
tour hopefully I'll see you guys there
at some of the events and you do the
same thing in your life the thing that
you are afraid to do is likely the thing
that will ultimately bring you the most
satisfaction and joy in your life and
you need to break through it you need to
press go I'm gonna give you a three step
process to conquer it step number one is
make a bold decision when you are
feeling bold you're feeling confident
you're feeling unstoppable and you make
a decision you say I want to do this I
feel like I can do that here's what
happens the next day the next hour even
maybe 10 minutes later you've lost some
of that boldness you've lost some of
that confidence you come up with a big
bold decision but then your head starts
talking you down from it you want to go
off on conquering through this amazing
thing and then almost immediately your
head starts talking you down finding all
the reasons why it's not gonna work
trying to find all the reasons why to
keep you safe the decisions that you
make when you are feeling bold or
unstoppable are actually the right
decisions for you those are the only
decisions that you should be listening
to and then you use your head to say we
are doing this help me figure out how to
do it instead of talking me down from
that big idea and so the next time you
are feeling bold you were feeling
unstoppable you're feeling filled with
confidence and you think I should go off
and do that that is the exact thing that
you need to be doing and pressing the Go
button on step number two is commit to
somebody else immediately when you
commit to somebody else you are much
more likely to follow through in my tour
as an example it started off as me doing
a free tour going to coffee shops and in
my New York coffee shop meetup as a
past we had too many people and and
didn't end up being a fantastic
experience because people couldn't hear
me and we didn't have seats for
everybody and then I went to meet my age
and he said you're playing small you got
to press the Go button you got a charge
for these things you got to make this a
bigger deal you have to make this more
important like spending time with you
matters and I made the decision that
night I'm gonna do this and I talked to
my agent and I committed to the people
on my team and now it's a lot harder for
me to back down because I committed to
somebody else so as soon as you make
that bold decision you've decided this
is the path I'm gonna take then
immediately not tomorrow not in an hour
not in 15 minutes like immediately
commit to somebody else before your head
talks you down for that big idea to say
I am doing this are you in and then step
number three is stopover planning people
over planning the over plan we over plan
you need to apply the 595 rule five
percent of your time planning and
thinking ninety-five percent of your
time doing five percent of your time
thinking planning strategizing and
ninety-five percent of your time doing
when you've made a decision this is what
I'm going to do this is the mark I wanna
make this is the new path for my life in
my business step one step two you've
committed to somebody else
you mean up your plan great don't look
at the plan for another three months doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo the reason
why people who are less talented than
you people who are less smart than you
are winning is because they are spending
time out doing taking action failing
learning getting better and you're
spending time on your couch or on your
computer thinking and tinkering and
planning and strategizing and none of
that stuff counts as actually doing you
need to stop over planning and start
taking more action so step number one
make a bold decision step number two
commit to somebody else immediately and
step number three stop over planning and
start taking massive action now I've got
a really special bonus tip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
bold move are you going to press go on
let me know put it in the comments below
but life cannot deny that someone who
gives their absolutely all what make
sure you use your whole self I'm not
talking about kind of do this kind of do
that kind of wake up kind of show up
kind of do this
anything you kind of need you'll get a
kind of result for why do fish while
robbing fish make it look so easy when
there's women they're flowing because
they use all of themselves birds you
look at they make it look so easy when
they fly because they use all of
themselves we don't use all of ourselves
because we've been given the dignity of
choice I choose not to wake up I choose
not to to go to this seminar and I
choose not to read this book and I
choose to read this gossip column and
all this stuff poisoning your mind you
don't have a shot-caller you're free to
do what you want position so I had a
problem where I had this dream I thought
the easy part would be getting to Bill
Gates the hard part I figured was
getting the money to fly there I was
buried in tuition payments I was all out
of Bar Mitzvah cash make some quick
money so two nights before final exams
my freshman year of college I find
tickets the price is right hey my first
thought is you know what if I go on the
show and win some money to fund this
dream yeah you know not my brightest
moment but I had a problem I never seen
a full episode of the show before I only
had seen bits and pieces so that night
had decided to do the logical thing and
pull an all-nighter to study okay but I
didn't study for finals I study how to
hack the prices right and I went on the
show the next day and did this
ridiculous strategy and ended up winning
the whole showcase showdown winning a
sailboat sells us over and that's how I
funded the book if you want more we'll
check it as top 50 rules video I think
you'll really enjoyed the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there I look at the world
through a lens of comedy my natural
reaction is always no matter when
something happens and I can't even help
it it's why is that funny